we're here at intelligentsia coffee with
my friend Jordan shlonsky now Jordan you
consider yourself a bit of a coffee
expert do you not enjoy coffee you enjoy
coffee and you enjoy coffee to the point
that you purchased with show money a
espresso maker is that right and had it
placed near your office was a reasonable
purchase reason well purchase but you
didn't ask me for it's not out of line
with the new a sleek rosy office did you
ask me for it no anyway we've
established the point that Jordan stole
from me and bought a espresso machine
that's how much he loves coffee this
gentleman right here is Sam is that
right Sam say I'm good to see you what
does intelligencia mean is it an Italian
word
it's an old political party during the
wars I see do you know do you know you
know Italian it's not an Italian word
okay all right but you know what it
means
except intelligentsia I was just told it
was an old political party to reward
you being a wiseass with me right now
that's what he just said that's why it
was still don't with me all right take
that power machine away from you and I
will stuff it down your pants I really I
will turn on that espresso machine
get it going with hot liquids and I will
shove it down the front of his pants and
watch it box and watch it cook his
scrotum and then you will add some latte
jourdonnais I see you eyeing this do you
want to buy this for the office this is
the same screen that Jordan sees in his
mind every time he tries to register an
emotion Jordan tell us what you know
about the roasting process well it's
important that when coffee is brewed the
beans are at the right level after the
roast
too soon the beans are still degassing
too late the beans have become stale I D
gassed about three minutes ago I love
this that's my favorite label that I've
seen in a long time and if we can see
that bean probe I must consult the beans
well what kind of bean is in there the
coffee from Guatemala
that's a Guatemalan bean you like a
Guatemalan bean I expect it's 100%
Arabica that's the trend today in most
modern coffee shops although
traditionally speaking the espresso in
Italy was a combination of Arabica and
robusta and the problem with single
origin is that often there's one flavor
profile so for your perfect cup of
coffee Jordan what do you want to take
yeah what's your perfect cup of coffee
my underlying flavor profile is
chocolate isn't that called cocoa
there's no what kids drink why don't you
just have a cup of cocoa in the morning
what you're saying is not logically
sounds walking about a flavor profile of
chocolate within coffee how do you like
your meat medium rare to rare so for
coffee
lighter roast is essentially a more
medium rare than a well-done I don't
agree with
you disagree with the coffee expert
coffee is like black truffle the true
flavor comes out only for heat hold me
back look at it it's perfect
has anyone ever fallen into this machine
and been mixed in with the beans
accidentally I'm gonna went to drink it
it was filled with human bone and blood
and gore Jordan wanting to take a closer
look Jordan just lean in okay Sam tell
us where are we now we're in the
cupboard that cupping room and we are
joined by the beautiful Eden so we're
gonna taste some coffee now tell us what
to do so each of these three cups is the
same coffee
some are blend some are single origin
coffees kind of flavors are you tasting
I'm getting coffee on this side of my
mouth
over here I'm getting more coffee in the
front I'm picking up strong hints of
coffee what are you getting Jordan hey
is fruitier you're getting a go I'll go
getting a guava mango for playoffs
papaya papaya are you getting papaya I'm
definitely not gonna keep any papaya you
know what you're having a small stroke
that's what's happening we could get you
to the hospital within the month I'm
really not rooting for you to win
you gotta stand out favorite either good
I like earthy qualities of certain
samples I like fruitier qualities of
other samples that he does where do you
guys stand on like putting a flavoring
into the coffee this is one that I enjoy
it's chocolate-chip cookie we put a lot
of effort working with our producers and
then Sam does his wonderfulness roasting
so we typically find that the chocolate
chip cookie overshadows the effort this
is my favorite right now I'm getting
milk now I'm getting a chocolate chip
cookie just try that place on that
anything that's it close your eyes does
that not take you back to childhood when
you come into the house it does and your
mother would say Jordan Jordan they make
you some cookies and then she'd pause
and say why don't you ever make eye
contact with me he's learned hey with
monoglycerides
is that this mr. favor this might be my
favorite yeah you know why
that's very good very different bases
for the string cafe campaña does exist
in Italy although this whip cream is an
artificially processed product once
again
what were you saying this is
artificially processed and overly sweet
there are no qualities of the cream that
come forward I inhaled a lot of the gas
propellant I have to say I think you'd
be fine
it only affects humans be good I think
the real art of espresso in particular
as a method of preparation is not so
much in the terms of the bean itself but
in the preparation of the beam I take
issue with the way a lot of coffee bars
in the United States prepare their
espresso I would rather watch this table
spin and listen to anything you have to
say what's gonna happen now we're gonna
be making drinks so I figured we start
with espresso since I've heard that's
what you're super Anton problem with
this process here is that again I prefer
the traditional style of seven grams of
coffee per 25 milliliters of water sure
what do you think is the American style
of espresso its fruity it's a little
over concentrated for my taste I don't
like the American coffee culture what
they perceived to be a good espresso as
an espresso that has had so much coffee
jammed into a small amount of water that
they suddenly perceive it as something
that they've never tasted before and
therefore it's good get him get him get
him so what we're looking for is we're
looking for the proper amount of
extraction for each coffee particle
based on that criteria based on the
actual solubles that we're extracting
but the issue is if I push it over 20 to
23 and I go towards my 30% extraction
those tannins are gonna overpower any of
the sugars and acids that we had in
there
tastic what you just did you just ripped
him anyway oh and I loved it
thank you thank you you got schooled son
bill today's pop what do you think we've
learned today have we learned anything I
think what we've learned is that coffee
like most of the sweetest things in life
is best enjoyed with people you care
about I'm gonna throw up
[Music]
[Applause]
you